at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking
can i answer your personal questions
[Music]
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal
[Music]
this episode is brought to you by ascent
protein i've been using a scent
as my primary protein powder for three
years now
it's clean efficient super easy on the
stomach
ever since i wrote the four hour body
starting my day with
at least 30 grams of protein has been
part of my routine it's part of the slow
carb diet
it's used to recompose your
body to lose fat etc it's very effective
ascent protein is the easiest way to get
this done
sometimes you just don't feel like
cooking a meal i trust ascent because
they offer what most companies can't
premium protein they control the
production
from start to finish they're vertically
integrated there are zero artificial
ingredients
zero artificial sweeteners and zero
added sugar they really do their
homework in r d this impressed me when i
was having tons of email back and forth
to try to assess them
as one example they tested 282 versions
of the chocolate flavor which
is my favorite before getting it just
right a few more things all ascent
products
are informed sports certified to be free
of banned substances
one scoop contains 25 grams of protein
and more
muscle repairing bcaas those are
branched chain amino acids then an
equivalent serving of chicken beef eggs
or
salmon they also are gluten free and soy
free
so you add one scoop or one and a half
scoops
to a shaker bottle that's what i do
let's say five to six ounces of water
and you can do that in the morning as i
do you can do post workout as i also do
after kettlebell swings and so on you
shake it up and you have a full serving
of elite protein in less than 60 seconds
so take a look check it out i have my
entire pantry stocked with this stuff
with the chocolate specifically check
out ascent protein that's a-s-c-e-n-t
protein dot com forward slash tim and
use the code
tim ascent for 20 off your purchase
again that's
ascentprotein.com tim
and use code tim ascent for 20 off the
discount code will also work on
amazon.com if you shop ascent protein
again it's tim ascent as a code for 20
off
this episode is brought to you by read
wise read wise is one of the cooler
things i've found
in the last year or two sent to me by
one of my best friends
it is an app that helps you remember
significantly more of what you
read in fact on average their users
report remembering 84
more of what they've read and
highlighted
and it can take a few different forms
you can sign up for the service
that's readwise.io forward slash tim
and get a daily email which i do so i've
got in front of me one example with
highlights from fooled by randomness
sapiens
priceless and a bunch of other books and
it has a bunch of
advanced features on top of that but
we've all had the experience of reading
a book or article
looking back a couple of weeks later to
realize that you don't remember anything
from it or next to nothing
read wise solves this problem by
integrating with kindle pocket
ibooks instapaper and more to send you a
daily digest of all your highlights
so it helps you to build a fun daily
habit i love getting these emails which
i can't believe i'm even saying cause i
hate email but i love getting these
so you get a daily email and simplest
form and you can review and actually use
the hundreds or perhaps even thousands
of highlights that are just sitting in
your reading devices collecting cyber
dust and this simple habit of reviewing
your highlights daily
can dramatically improve how much
information you retain through spaced
repetition and actually
use and quite frankly it's just fun it's
really fun to see what you've
highlighted over the years and forgotten
about
some of it's really good i mean these
are things that ostensibly you wanted to
remember
readwise also provides tools for
organizing your books articles and
highlights
so tagging searching adding notes
creating flash cards
all that kind of stuff you can even tell
read wise to automatically export your
highlights to evernote
this is a big deal for me i've had to do
this manually in the past but read wise
makes it
painless and super super simple and it
just takes
seconds to sign up i was astonished by
this i thought the importing from the
kindle would take a really long time
it takes no time at all and believe it
or not you can also use read wise
with paper books that is if you have a
paperback or something you can
automatically get the top popular
highlights for your books simply by
adding their titles
and you can also create your own
highlights with the app's camera
highlighting feature
this stuff is super cool so there's no
reason not to try this out i think it's
incredibly incredibly useful incredibly
cool and very fun
go to readwise.io forward slash tim
that's readwise.io forward slash tim for
two month free trial
offered exclusively to tim ferriss show
listeners again that's readwise.io
forward slash tim for a two month free
trial read wise dot io
forward slash tim check it out
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the tim ferriss
show my guest today is a friend blake
mykoski you can find him on twitter
facebook
instagram at blakemykoskymycoski
blake is a serial entrepreneur that's an
understatement philanthropist and
best-selling author most known for
founding tom's shoes
and is the person behind the concept of
one for one which of course
you've run into at some point synth a
business model that helps a person in
need with every product
purchased tom's shoes has provided
nearly 96 million pairs of shoes to
children
around the globe since its inception in
2014
after selling half of the company at
bain capital blake stepped down as ceo
of toms
utilizing half of his proceeds he
started the social entrepreneurship fund
to help early startups with core social
missions get off the ground with much
needed funding
since then he's invested in more than 25
social enterprises
and has also expanded his philanthropic
efforts to include the funding of the
center
for psychedelic and consciousness
research at johns hopkins making it the
first such research center in the us and
the largest of its kind in the world
in the spring of 2020 that is right
about now blake co-founded his newest
company
made for getmade4.com 10-month program
that applies the principles of modern
neuroscience psychology and physiology
to make your brain and body better
created alongside scientists from
stanford harvard and other top
universities
made for all one word m-a-d-e-f-o-r
helps people learn and sustain positive
habits and practices that have the
greatest impact
on their lives blake welcome back to the
show
thanks tim it's good to be here we have
had many many conversations over the
years and i want to say
context for folks that we have done a
podcast episode
previously in person where we cover a
lot
of the tom's story so we won't
duplicate that here but i think it's
important to provide at least a little
bit of context for folks and for those
who want to find the earlier episode you
can just go to
tim dot blog forward slash podcast and
search blake
and it'll pop right up i think it's
number 249
which is incredibly almost 200
episodes ago wow that's crazy
it's bonkers and you and i have had many
life changes
gone through many chapters that's for
sure it just feels like lifetimes
and to paint a picture if we go back in
time
for folks who know you for thomas but
maybe not
the collection of other businesses that
you've started so at
29 now you're older than 29 now of
course but at 29 you'd already done
not necessarily in this order but
outdoor advertising driver's education
laundry and built a television
network i got busy early
you got busy early and your family story
is incredible we won't necessarily
duplicate all of that just as an
anecdote for folks your parents
literally used to sell their blood to
pay their rent i believe because they
were so poor during
medical school there's a certain amount
of initiative
uh in the family it would seem but what
would you say
drove you or compelled you to start
all of these businesses if you're sort
of looking under the hood
knowing what you know now what is it
that has driven you to build all of
these things
and it doesn't have to be a single
answer but i'm just i'm so curious
since you are so so incredibly
productive
and just back to back to back have done
so much
how would you begin to speak to that i
would say the
the thing that probably is the greatest
contributor to that was
the discipline and drive that i learned
as a young child trying to become a
professional tennis player
my whole life growing up from age nine
or ten
was you know practicing tennis living at
tennis academies training
and it was not one of those situations
where my parents
you know pushed it on me if anything
they thought i was a little bit obsessed
and they worried about
my you know drive um for at such a young
age but i really
when i look back at my entrepreneurial
career those early businesses i think
were just
new vehicles for me to compete and for
me
to build an identity like i did as a
great tennis player as a young child
what made you
a good tennis player we know you didn't
go on to
necessarily focus your entire life on
tennis but
what was it that made you a good
competitor right there many different
types of competitors
to be completely honest i was not very
talented um
you know naturally i worked really
really hard and i mean i lived at this
one academy with some of the top players
in the world
the john newcomb tennis academy when i
was 15
and out of you know 50 top players from
around the world that are worldly ranked
and go on to become
you know professionals i won the hardest
worker
of the year award and that was the only
way that i could even compete
with some of those players was just
because i outworked them and so
i don't know if that's a nature versus
nurture thing
because i think you know i have a
two-year-old daughter now and she's
so freaking driven i mean like she goes
to swim lessons and just swims across
the pool and never looks up to see
for applause or anything like i see that
eye of the tiger in her
and i definitely had that at a young age
i mean from the day that my parents gave
me my first tennis racket and i got a
tennis lesson
i wouldn't come home till it was dark
and often times i would convince them to
leave the lights on
for me to hit against the backboard and
so i think that was in my nature just
just incredibly
self-disciplined and driven and that's
what allowed me to
excel as far as i did as a tennis player
but you really need
the natural talent too to go pro and you
took the
the drive the discipline the work ethic
and applied it to businesses and
of course i would imagine there are
people listening who go well great his
two-year-old daughter has
the superior software pre-installed
what am i going to emulate here and
and the next question is really on the
nurture side so i think all of us come
into this world with
a certain set of software a certain set
of hardware
and sometimes the harder things to do
are those
that run against or are on the opposite
end of the spectrum from our
innate programming right sure so for
some people listening
if they are say less driven perhaps they
have to cultivate themselves to be
driven but
if you are building and building a
building
as you did for a very long time and
still are
but let's flash forward to 2012. so i'm
recording this
right now from austin texas and i
believe
this is where you moved for a sabbatical
yeah 2012. now you
when i think of you and the reason i'm
laughing is
just like i imagine you going kind of
insane
doing a sabbatical that that may be
unfair but are so
high rpm i'd love to just hear you
describe the
decision for the sabbatical how it came
to be
and and what was done during the
sabbatical yeah i mean what was done is
not pretty
and it almost led to a divorce at one
year after getting married
i'll get to that in a second um but what
the decision that led to it was
um you know i i've been an entrepreneur
since i was 19 years old
um so by 2012 i had you know been doing
it for
16 17 years toms was
a very successful business you know
driving hundreds of millions of dollars
in sales and helping millions of
children around the world
i had just gotten married and
for the first time my life i just wanted
to take a break i mean i just
i was i just needed to have some time to
kind of reflect on
all these companies this new
relationship i was in
this new commitment i had made in
getting married and
i always thought i would move back to
texas that was a big part of it too you
know i grew up in texas and
you know i think anyone who grows up in
texas that leaves and especially maybe
ends up living in la or new york city or
san francisco
they love the excitement and the
adrenaline and the uniqueness of those
cities but
you can't really ever take texas out of
a texan and so i always thought
you know once i got married once i
started thinking about family
austin texas would be back where i need
to be and
and and that was a big driver in the
sabbatical too so it was to take some
time to reflect
to see how stable toms was on its own
without my day-to-day
you know running it um and to you know
really kind of explore whether texas is
going to be
the the long-term uh place for for me
and and heather at that time so that was
the decision now what happened was
uh pretty much a disaster because i had
to put my attention to something and so
i like to play golf and i like to drink
beer and so
i pretty much spent all day drinking
beer and playing golf
which does not make you exactly the most
attractive husband when you
have to take a taxi home at the end of
the day because you can't drive
was there anything you took away from
your experience with the sabbatical
i mean it sounds like a decent pressure
release
valve at least for a period of time but
was there value in the experience sure i
think
the value was is really understanding no
matter how much you love a hobby
or you need releases and you know play
in your life
the joy in those things is lost if you
don't
have balance and you don't have some
type of meaningful work
and responsibilities to balance it so
you know i cut to now
i'm an avid mountain climber i race cars
you know and i love surfing but
i don't do that all day every day or i
wouldn't enjoy those things and because
i have
a father and i've got you know lots of
investments and
now a new company and so having that
balance
is what allows you to really enjoy the
leisure activities or the hobbies and
when your hobbies become your full-time
job in a sense it quickly uh
deteriorates the joy you're deriving
from it and i definitely experienced
that and that's where
you know ultimately i decided i need to
move back to california and
get back involved in toms after uh after
only eight months
part of the reason that we're having
this conversation is
that you've had many life transitions
in the last few years you've had many
new experiences
uh transformative inputs of different
types and i've always viewed you as
a a seeker and
i'd like to talk about or have you talk
about
one that comes to mind that we've talked
about when not recording just over
dinners and so on but
the hoffman process sure could you speak
to the hoffman process what is it
why did you participate in it yeah the
hoffman process i mean there's probably
three three to four experiences or
practices that i've taken on in my life
that have
by far had the greatest impact in a
positive way
and i love to start with a hoffman
process because
it is at the top of the list the hoffman
process is
an eight day program that bob hoffman
started
30 plus years ago it came out of eslin
and its main concept is focused around
this thing called the negative love
syndrome
that we all experience from our parents
or primary caregivers
regardless of if they're the greatest or
the
or the worst so every single
child has this experience and basically
what it is is
when we're young we are very astute to
our primary caregivers patterns
and their behaviors and we do one of two
things with pretty much
every single pattern and behavior of our
parents in my case
and that is we either emulate the
pattern or the behavior to receive their
love
or we do the exact opposite
to demand their attention and so this is
as a child how we survive and bob
hoffman and
a lot of really really smart people have
studied this from a psychological
perspective
and so what happens is the way that our
brains get wired
and all the patterns that end up driving
pretty much every decision in our life
after the age of 12 are hardwired in
there based on
us wanting to either receive love or
attention
from our parents now some of those
patterns go on to help us
in innumerable ways i would say you know
my drive and competitiveness
has blessed me in many many ways but
i like to be competitive or have drive
now
as a conscious choice versus a pattern
that i can't turn
on or off in any situation because
sometimes like
it's not healthy to be incredibly
competitive um
you know in a romantic relationship it's
probably not that healthy
definitely not with your five-year-old
son i mean there's a lot of times in
which i
am glad that i can recognize and see
that pattern happening
but then you know dampen it for the
situation but the hoffman process
what you do when you go there is it's a
they take you through a series of
exercises it's very experiential
and it's very unconventional but it is
more effective than anything i've ever
seen
and through the week what you do is you
really recognize
what patterns you have from both of your
parents that you want to let go of
that aren't serving you anymore you also
then see
these vicious cycles that play out in
your life and so these are
macro patterns if you look through 20 30
years you can kind of see like
oh i do this and it leads to this and
ultimately leads to this
and that has really not served me and so
then they
give you the tools to really rewire your
brain in a way
so that you're not a slave to these
patterns and habits and it's the most
freeing experience ever i mean it is i
mean one of my favorite things i love to
talk about hoffman is
and this is definitely not anything that
they would ever promote is is an
expectation to have
but i went to hoffman in 2000
and i want to say 16.
and after hoffman i remember coming back
to the tom's office
and our ceo at the time he's like man
you look lighter
like physically lighter and i was like i
feel lighter
and then over the next couple weeks i
literally lost
12 pounds in any body fat i had
in my abdominal area where a lot of men
carry body fat because of stress
and anxiety and i literally went from
having you know i wasn't overweight but
to having like
crazy abs and everyone was like what did
you do and i'm like
i didn't do a single [ __ ] crunch i
just went to hoffman
and i mean and literally i lost weight
as i lost
mental weight and so um since then
i have started a scholarship fund i've
sent over
200 people that have needed the
financial backing or resources to go
and i've also sent pretty much every
single one of my friends and family
and it's the only thing in my life that
it bats a thousand
there's not a single person that hasn't
come back and said that was the most
important week of my life and it helps
you become a better parent it helps you
become
a better spouse if it helps you become a
better leader for sure
and i've gone back and done graduate
work there and i continue to
support them financially so more people
can go that can't afford it
but yeah it is i mean i have goosebumps
over my whole body
just getting the opportunity to share
how meaningful hoffman was because i'm
so grateful to it a bunch of different
things i want to dig
into here thank you for that explanation
the first is really a footnote
related to the the losing of abdominal
fat
that that doesn't actually surprise me
in the in the sense that if if for
whatever reason you have dramatically
lowered your cortisol levels
there's a cascade of different effects
that one might observe and certainly
in men that that would be a sort of
redistribution or change in how
fat is deposited or retained right and
cortisol is such an incredibly powerful
hormone you need it to
live you don't want to go without
cortisol but just as an example for
folks
who might have this experience if you've
ever been tired and wired
where you're physically exhausted you
try to go to bed and then you're just
racing a million miles a minute what
often happens is
you have this release of cortisol then a
spike of glucose
and you feel like you're on the start
line for running a marathon
it's very frustrating so i actually
sometimes take phosphatidylserine this
supplement
one or two hundred milligrams before bed
to help with that
that's kind of blunt that cortisol
response but
that's the footnote now that i said that
back to the hoffman process
are you open to sharing any of the
patterns or cycles that ended up being
very helpful to identify
yeah i mean i'll share one and it's it's
uh
embarrassing but i think it's
embarrassing because it's so
it's just it was such a driver in my
life um and i think some people will
really connect to this so by and it's a
good example of how your parents can do
all the right things and you're still
going to have these patterns
so my mom did not graduate from college
supported my dad through medical school
selling her blood waiting tables you
know
had as my dad became this very
successful
uh doctor you know she was serving as a
housewife and
didn't have the same sense of i would
say pride that my dad did in his
vocation and when she had me i was
not only the first child in our family
but i was the first grandchild in a very
big
mykoski family and so my mom all of a
sudden
got you know kind of held up in
incredible high regards by everyone by
giving
my grandparents a the first grandchild
and and i was
literally the apple of her eye and i
could do no wrong
i was just loved at every single
second in minute i mean her whole world
revolved around me
and so i grew up even when i did have
brothers and sisters which she also
gave the same love to them there was
always something special of me being the
first
not just by my mom but i would say the
whole kind of aunts
uncles grandparents everyone and so i
grew up
really experiencing high levels of
attention
at all moments in my life and so the
pattern that came from that
was i needed to be the center of
attention
to feel comfortable and now this
is a not very attractive characteristic
and a friendship and definitely romantic
relationships which we'll get to because
it all comes full circle tim
and so what i learned in hoffman
and i'll give you a very specific
example because it's embarrassing
slightly disgusting now to me but i have
beat it so i it makes me very happy
and that is it was so hardwired into my
brain to be the center of attention
and to be praised by people that i would
get on a ski lift i love snowboarding
and i'd get on a ski lift and before we
got to the top of the lift
i would subconsciously manipulate the
conversation so they would ask me
what i did for a living and then i would
get to say i'm the founder of
toms in which unanimously you get praise
you know you built a business to help
millions of children
wow like i mean and so literally i would
like not be comfortable on that ski lift
until that conversation happened and
then once i got the praise and the
attention
i could focus on anything that the other
person was talking but
it was so hardwired into me and now that
i say that it's just like
so embarrassing but i never knew that
until i went to hoffman and then once i
went to hoffman and i said
to myself okay there's a healthy amount
of
you know needing attention and love you
know to feel secure
but mine is totally out of whack based
on this pattern
and here are the things that happen when
this pattern starts to get triggered
and now i almost play games at like
parties or ski lifts
where i lead the conversation every
which way possible so people never
find out that i'm the founder of toms
and it's beautiful and it gives me this
sense of like deep spiritual connection
to my
spiritual self as they would say in
hoffman and so that's just one small
example but i think it gives you an idea
of how
some of these patterns can even come
from really positive things your parents
did not just traumatic now a lot of them
come from trauma
too so if you've had a traumatic
experience i think kaufman's even
more effective in helping you process
some of that trauma but yeah that's an
example
um that i think illustrates how
hardwired these patterns are in you
many people listening
shame for shame no i'm kidding it's it's
uh you know the uh
what is it a problem well stated as a
problem half solved i mean you have to
develop
i think that was john dewey if i'm
getting the attribution right but it
starts with an awareness right
and yes and developing the
perspective so that you can be aware of
the stories and the narratives and the
patterns that are governing
your behavior whether you're aware of
them or not at the outset
it's a question for you about the
hoffman process a lot of people
listening will be very interested
in doing something like the hoffman
process some very very small percentage
will probably end up going but it's
going to be a small percentage
are there any books or
resources that help people to
achieve some of the progress that one
might
at the hoffman process right or their
books like to
a few come to mind like awareness by
anthony demello for me
or man i can't believe you said that
book i literally i i gave that book to
someone very special a couple days ago
it's one of my favorite books
no kidding i did not know that i love
anthony demillo i mean i've read
everything i mean rediscovering life i
think is
should be like every single human should
read that
um because that is such a powerful
experience and i think it's to answer
your question rediscovering life is
another one i would say besides
awareness
specifically are in this in this genre
great are there any other resources
you might recommend i don't know if the
hoffman process does anything
outside of the in-person events that are
more widely available you know they they
don't um because the process is and
i think this is important to state is
like i definitely think
some of anthony demello's books for sure
uh rediscovering life
awareness i think that there is a book
actually kind of written about the
hoffen process it's not an official
hoffman book but if you
google hoffman process book you'll find
it i forget what it's called
it kind of talks through it but the
reason hoffman is so effective
is that it is a totally immersive
experience
that you do without giving away some of
the secrets because it's really fun
because knowing that's part of the as a
graduate you never tell people what
they're going to do because you you need
to have the
surprise and the experiences unfold but
it's
you use your body you use your mind use
your
i mean you kind of you have to do it
it's not just something you learn
it's something you actually physically
experience through different
very unique practices that you do there
that release things and
and open up patterns that you're not
even aware of and memories that you
don't even have
consciously so you know hoffman has
scholarships
i from time to time if you follow me on
instagram i post scholarships you know
at least a couple times a year but you
know if this is something that is of
interest to you
i think you know do anything you
possibly can to get and do the process
because
it is something that is and i've read
every book in the world in this genre
and nothing compares to the actual
experience
so having covered at least for the time
being the hoffman process and i should
say for people listening that i wanted
to have this conversation with you
for a few different reasons one of them
is that you've experienced these
transitions like i mentioned and that
whether people identify with you or not
right because you're talking about
racing cars
you've built a company that had hundreds
of millions of dollars in revenue
and i think that there's the possibility
that someone listening says well
i have very little in common with blake
so i wonder or even doubt if these tools
will apply to me
i anticipate that and the reason that i
still think this conversation is of
value is that
whether you're going through a midlife
crisis an
end of life crisis a quarter life crisis
where you're
graduating and you don't know what you
want to be when you grow up
or going through a divorce or
contemplating getting married having
kids having kids leave the house
during these transition periods a lot of
material comes up
yeah and the material is going to be
unique to each and every person but
the tools a lot of the tools i think are
quite
flexible so that's just really more of a
commentary that i wanted to to mention
but before we keep going in the case of
the hoffman process you mentioned you
were going through a difficult stage
are you open to saying more sure about
what that was
yeah i mean i i think selling half of
the company
selling half of toms and uh stepping
down and hiring a ceo
and became a father for the first time
this is all five years ago was
incredibly
challenging because all of those things
were the things that i had been
told by my parents and society and
culture would make me happy
you know i now have full financial
freedom i have
time freedom because i have a ceo
running the company so i can do other
things
focus on being a dad hobbies i'm married
i have a child
i have great friends so i took the
discipline that we started this
conversation
talking about and applied it to
everything that i thought
would bring me joy peace and fulfillment
and all of those things were externally
focused
and so once i realized that i had
accomplished everything i set out to do
and i was still waking up feeling very
challenged
very not motivated not feeling like i
had a purpose
low energy levels having trouble
sleeping which ultimately
you know led to being diagnosed for the
first time my life with mild depression
um i realized the most important thing
or i had a i want to say realize then i
realized it now but i had a
inclination that
the external would never be the thing
that would
allow me to feel what i had been seeking
and so that began and it started with
hofmann and
it also led to you know plant medicine
journeys and it led to
my two years of research with different
scientists that led to the made-for
program but all that came from
looking inward maybe for the first time
in my life
and i'm incredibly grateful today
because i've never felt
that i've been living in a state of
flourishing more than i am now and it
has nothing to do with any
of the external things that most people
know me for you mentioned
maybe 10 15 minutes ago three to four
practices you know a handful of
practices one of which
is the hoffman process what are some of
the others
that have stood out for you in terms of
positive impact so i would say
i would define these as experiences and
then
the third experience led to some very
specific
daily simple practices so let's start
with the experience the experiences were
hoffman plant medicine journeys
ayahuasca
and psilocybin to be specific that i was
able to do down in south america
and then the third was and this is
pretty much
what i'm spending all my time or most of
my time on now
the third was spending time with some of
the top scientists at the
best universities in the country seeing
what has scientifically been proven
that can affect your mental well-being
on a day-to-day basis so not
huge you know experiences like hofmann
or plant medicine
but the small steps that you can do
every single day so
practices and habits that can insulate
you
from the challenges of modern living and
setting out
and really almost approaching it like a
student
and being able to get access to this
incredible
body of science specifically in the in
the neuroscience
with andrew huberman out of stanford
university
that has given me the day-to-day
insulation from all the challenges and
especially recently during covet 19.
um so those are the three things really
hoffman plant medicine
and the practices that ultimately led to
the made-for program that i practice
every day
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by
element spelled lmnt
element is a delicious sugar-free
electrolyte drink mix
i've stocked up on boxes and boxes of
this usually use
one to two per day my favorite flavor is
citrus salt
also makes an amazing margarita but you
can also take it before long hikes and
things like that which is what i'm doing
right now in the summer element is
formulated to help anyone with
electrolyte needs it's perfectly suited
also to those who are fasting say
intermittent fasting longer stuff
or following a keto low carb or paleo
diet when supplemental electrolytes can
relieve hunger
cramps headaches tiredness and dizziness
who needs any of that
so you can try it totally risk-free if
you don't like it element will give you
your money back
no questions asked rob wolf is behind
this
it's high-end high-grade effective stuff
element has a very special offer for you
guys they've created
tim's club i don't get any kickback or
anything
it's just called tim's club simply go to
drinkelement.com that's drinklmnt.com
forward slash tim and use promo code
tim's club to get the 30 count box of
element for just
36 this will be valid for the lifetime
of the subscription and you can pause it
or cancel it anytime again that's drink
element dot com
slash tim for this exclusive offer using
promo code
tim's club one more time drink lmnt.com
forward slash tim
promo code tim's club
so we're gonna spend a good amount of
time on the the day-to-day
installation right the practices because
it's very easy
as you and i both know because we have
spent time around people who
practice what one might call spiritual
bypass
they use some
substance to vaporize themselves into
stardust
and and and then the insight
falls like grains of sand through the
the fingers
in their psyche and two weeks later they
are
behaving the same way with the same
subconscious drivers remaining
subconscious right there's
these compounds and these peak
experiences
uh hoffman or otherwise i would imagine
although i don't want to speak for
hoffman but
i would imagine there are people who
they don't make the translation
from the experience to practice and
nonetheless i would be very interested
to hear what
you feel you gained from your plant
medicine experiences
sure because you as i mentioned in the
introduction and
i'd like to extend my thanks yet again
for
being a very substantial supporter of
the scientific research related to
psychedelics
and i've been most notably so that's
i think an incredible way to bend the
arc
of history as it relates to treating
psychiatric disorders that
have largely been untreatable so thank
you for that
of course on a personal on a personal
level what were your experiences
yeah so i think the the first experience
was with
ayahuasca down in south america and
starting with the big guns i mean that's
just the kind of
the foreplay yeah just get the poor way
at work
i would not recommend that by the way um
so if you're listening to this and is
this something you're interested in
i would definitely start with something
like a guided
uh psilocybin journey with a you know
medium to small dose
but i went with the big guns and i think
it just shows the desperation that i was
feeling at that time
you know aya really just revealed
the the expansiveness
of my consciousness of time
of the inner connection of nature and
all beings
and in a way that the takeaway was
and this is really goes back to some of
maybe the childhood wounds that i still
carry
that also are part of the reason i was
so driven
was just a feeling i remember coming out
of it and just almost like angels around
me
just saying you are all right you are
enough
you don't need to prove anything to
anyone ever again
just enjoy your human experience
like it was just this like it was just
like this deep
it wasn't the praise that i had always
sought it was a
deep love and acknowledgement that
there's nothing more i can do or nothing
i can't do
to not feel god's love and i had heard
about that in the christian faith i'd
heard about that in
other spiritual teachings but to feel
that
in a way that was so powerful
and just mine expanding was really one
of the things i'm most grateful for in
my life because i
literally came out came back to the us
and came back to my regular life and i
really believe i have integrated that
into my you know personal outlook
and self-compassion and all these other
more practices
that we'll get into but it started with
that just
a total awakening that happened through
aya
around just how much more is that play
and because it's so enormous and it's so
we're such as we're a small part of such
something so beautiful and perfectly
designed
that it gave me this peace that i
am just perfect the way i am and i
remember hearing that in sunday school
as a kid
and never having it ever really resonate
um and it totally transformed the way i
looked at myself
after that experience i appreciate you
sharing that description
and it's just never ceases to
make me crack a smile when anyone
including yours truly tries to put one
of these experiences into words
yeah thanks for making me do that you're
welcome
and uh it's it is certainly
an unusual yet completely familiar
feeling to
have some of these experiences which is
an odd combination perhaps but there's a
lot of paradox that makes complete sense
when you are having these experiences
to perhaps provide a contrast just
because what you described sounds
incredibly euphoric have you had
any difficult
plant medicine experiences yes so the
second
ayahuasca i i now talk about ayah
like a knee surgery so if you ever feel
compelled to do it
[Laughter]
if you ever do feel compelled and i do
not think it's for everyone i want to be
very clear and i do think it is
you know something you might want to
work up to and i think and i
for instance i have several friends that
have wanted to get the information about
where i did my ayahuasca experience and
i have almost demanded that they go to
hoffman before they do ayahuasca
because i feel that a lot of other work
can help prepare you so that your
experience can be more positive
but the reason i say it's like a knee
surgery is i had that incredible
blissful
mind expanding heart opening experience
and for some reason two years later
curiosity got the best of me i decided
to do it again
and i i took a you know a pretty big
dose
went back down south and i had a
horrifying experience
that i have still spent you know several
years trying to really
understand the meaning and the
integration and you and i've talked
about this before
it was not only incredibly frightening
because
i had this experience that the entire
reality that we know
is not real and that it was all just a
dream that i'm having and
and i even created god to make the dream
more interesting
um and so then that what was i and i
just went to this rabbit hole of like
as if life was a video game that i'd
played a billion times and
every time i played i add one little
thing like i wear a blue shirt instead
of a white shirt because
i don't know i got to do something
different i mean it literally just and
so everything felt meaningless
so that was horrifying because i have so
much meaning in my regular life and so
now
i had this experience that where the
whole thing felt like a meaningless
video game
the funniest part about that is so tim
is in that ayahuasca experience
i had this like moment where i was like
shark attacks
damn that's a bug in my video game i
need to next time i need to go back and
have sharks stop attacking people
because they were never meant
to bite people and that is a bug in the
game that i created and i like obsessed
over that
flaw in this perfectly designed human
experience video game
um
and if i can add one thing to that too
and uh we can certainly cut this
if it's talking out of school but
one of the aspects of that that i recall
being very disconcerting to you
is that that feeling of being in a
simulation didn't end when you left
south america there were nights when you
would wake up
and turn to your partner
and say is this real am i real
and you were unsure right yes there was
a
this was a real question that was that
was that was the part i was going to get
to that was the most scary so the
experience itself was
what i would call unsettling unpleasant
caused me to have a state of i you know
i think
of you know just confusion and then
for the week after i got home i had
several nights where i woke up
and i felt like i was back in the
medicine
and that's the thing that was so scary
and i remember calling you and asking
for advice
at the time and anyone else i know who
had you know experienced these things
and that was um the the thing that was
so scary and that's why i call it a knee
surgery it's like i had a beautiful knee
surgery my knee worked fine
and i don't know why i decided to try to
have another knee surgery so
um so for the time being unless i'm
desperately called back to
ayahuasca i um i do feel that i can gain
something from the plants it's uh
it's with psilocybin and
i don't know if you remember when we
spoke i remember this conversation i
remember exactly where i was when we had
this conversation
do you remember the nickname that i had
for your experience because this is the
scary
night school and one of the most
horrifying thought spirals you can have
is that what you're experiencing is
unique to you right that there is
there's some unique form of madness that
you have descended into
and so you describe this where you go to
sleep and then you feel like you've gone
right back into the experience
what some people might call flashbacks
let's just say and
that as i mentioned and the nickname is
actually from a friend of mine named
michael
michael c i'll give him credit he calls
it night school
because it is relatively common with
ayahuasca and particularly with
five methoxy dmt or 5mu dmt
and that can persist as i mentioned in
some people for
a few days in some people for 10 days at
least anecdotally among the
sample size that i've had contact with
and that can be horrifying particularly
if
that expectation or possibility has not
been laid out ahead of time
yes and which is why i you know it's
funny you say knee surgery because i
actually uh we arrived at the same
metaphor
completely separately when i talked to
people about these types of compounds or
plants
i describe the process as knee surgery
not just because you're having knee
surgery
but because if you don't do your rehab
afterwards
you could end up worse off than you were
before there's a period of plasticity a
window
of malleability within which you can
change things and
shape things but whether it's shaped for
the better or not depends a lot on your
on your behaviors and so on so just a
real quick note on this
because you and i have had many
conversations about this and a lot of
people listening
i think we'll have a lot of enthusiasm
around this subject
and i want to just say a couple of quick
things is a
sort of public service announcement the
first is that
psychedelics and use of psychedelics in
my opinion should not be an arms race
it's not like you
need to escalate from bunny slope to
intermediate black diamond to double
black to hella skiing to
free fall you don't need to use all
these compounds and if
you look at indigenous cultures
that have used these plants very often
they have their lane
in other words the the mushrooms used by
the mausotex in central america
are not the same as used as the
say ayahuasca used by certain tribes
in peru also the ayahuasca and certain
tribes of peru may not be the exact same
ayahuasca used by
other tribes in say columbia or
different locations so there's a
tremendous amount of variance
and none of these people use
the entire catalog of psychedelics found
globally that's a very western
yes experience and perspective and i
think there are
incredible risks associated with it the
second thing i'll say is for people who
might be interested you
you mentioned insisting on hoffman
process first i think that
it is a very good idea to develop
a basic fluency with some of the
easier tools before you go for these
peak
experiences which can be incredibly
life-affirming and transformational
and they can also be incredibly
destructive there's just a
there's a survivorship bias so you don't
hear about these stories very much but i
know
of not just one not just two but at
least six to 12 people firsthand
who have been knocked sideways and
destabilized for weeks or months
after use of ayahuasca and five muodmt
specifically
so it's so what i would say is the
progression
since you mentioned hoffman i'll just
kind of mention what i usually advise
to people who are going to take it
seriously is that you
use something like the waking up
meditation app for
30 days no substances this is completely
sober
you read awareness by anthony demello
you watch the six part series the power
of myth which is bill moyers
interviewing joseph campbell
you schedule at least two sessions of
holotropic breath work
again completely sober but you are able
to
experience in a non-ordinary state of
consciousness that is produced
through breathing techniques then and
again
this is this is where we get into
riskier
legal territory so i'm going to say i'm
not advising breaking any laws
but mdma assisted psychotherapy would be
the next step after that
then guided psilocybin
and you can stop at that point you can
actually stop at any of those points
previously you don't have to continue to
proceed but
i would not use ayahuasca until you have
done all of those things
amen i'm so i mean for if for no other
reason i know hopefully
people will gain a lot from this
conversation and i know that's our
intention
but for no other reason i'm glad that
you uh laid that out because i don't
think
that type of prescription is shared
enough in our society right now
thank you blake and i um it's it's uh
it's really nice to have a companion on
the path by the way with the
the support of the science which i i do
deeply deeply believe in
um let's let's talk about if if you've
got time i've got time i know we don't
have a hard stop which is a rare luxury
but i there are a few things i want to
make sure that we talk about
i want to get into the day-to-day
installation that third bucket so to
speak that you mentioned
first i'd like to ask about conscious
uncoupling because i really think this
will be of tremendous service to a lot
of people listening
including those people who are not in a
state of crisis but
could you provide some context for what
that
means and how it came to be
uh something you're familiar with yes
absolutely and i mean it's one of the
reasons why i was excited to
have this conversation with you because
i went through a very very powerful
experience with my now ex-wife heather
over the last
seven months with this concept of
conscious uncoupling so
heather and i were married for seven
years and over
those seven years almost after the first
year we had challenges and we worked at
it and with the same discipline and
drive
that we've talked about we did lots of
therapy
we worked with some of you know i'm not
going to name names with some of the
therapists that everyone has watched
their ted talks
um we you know did pretty much every
kind of
therapeutic intervention we could to try
to find
what was holding us back from the type
of love and relationship that we both
dreamed of having
and we i think having two kids
definitely was
something that kept us working hard at
it because we both
wanted to make sure that we were
providing the best
environment for them but over the last
year to two years we recognized that
we were starting to fight more we were
starting to you know the energy level
was not good in the home
and the kids were starting especially
our five-year-old to pick up on it and
asking us like why are we fighting and
what's wrong with mom or what's wrong
with dad or and we also just started
kind of living separate lives and you
know we're young i mean
i'm 43 and heather's 38 and
and we said there's more to this and and
and we and we also never really lost our
friendship in all this
um and so that's a long way of saying we
decided
back in september of last year that
we would be better off not being married
anymore
and i read catherine woodward's book
conscious uncoupling
um while we made this decision and i
gave it to heather and she read it
and we were blown away by the concepts
of it i mean if you think about it over
50 percent
of people who get married are going to
ultimately get divorced
yet we have very few tools in our
society
and very few role models to show us a
way of doing it where you can
actually create a new relationship a new
agreement that's more powerful
and more beautiful than the one that you
entered in when you said i do
and specifically for your kids and your
mutual friends
that are often the collateral damage
when people get divorced
and so we had the benefit of working
with some coaches so
not only um is the book really valuable
but on the website they have a resource
of different coaches for all different
budgets
to help you through the process if you
if you so choose i highly recommend that
and what the process did is it helped us
really see
a little bit in the sphere of hoffman
and patterns like
who were we when we got married and why
did we really choose to get married and
what expectations were not fulfilled and
what disappointments do we have and
and really at the end of the day you
realize kind of like so much of this
it was not about blaming the other
person it was about owning
what my role was in those unmet
expectations
or loss of sexual polarity or
all the things that ultimately lead to a
couple willing to split
and by us doing that work individually
for several months first and then
together as a couple
we were able to create a beautiful new
future for us
and um the interesting thing and i think
the reason why this is very time
relevant
is we literally got through the whole
program divorce became finals signed all
the paperwork
heather was gonna get a wonderful home
just you know 15 minutes down the road
for me and the kids were going to go
back and forth and
we were ready to start a beautiful new
chapter this spring
and then covet 19 happens and
we then found ourselves quarantined once
again as a family
with now my ex-wife for two months after
we had you know really been kind of
looking forward to this new chapter
but i am so grateful that happened
because it allowed us to test
everything that we learned and
everything that we committed
in a very tight living situation with
kids home all day long with no other
external forces
and what we found was our friendship got
solidified
better than ever and the support that we
have for each other is is
absolutely beautiful our kids can feel
it they're thriving they see the love
and now that heather has moved into her
other house and the kids are going back
and forth
there's been no trauma issues with the
kids and so
it has been a beautiful beautiful
experience and i think heather and i are
both so much more well prepared
for whatever relationships we enter into
the future because we
have awareness now that we didn't have
when
we kind of just stumbled upon into our
first relationship
you know nine years ago so the book is
incredible
the coaches are amazing i can't stress
enough that there is a
beautiful alternative to staying in an
unhappy marriage
or an unhappy boyfriend girlfriend i
mean it doesn't have to be a marriage it
could be
any type of relationship and i just am
so deeply grateful for the experience we
had the last seven months
could you speak to or just
describe some of the things that you are
now aware of
or give even one example yeah just uh i
mean
for sure well i think that you know one
of the things that i recognized
was my parents actually last week
celebrated their 50th wedding
anniversary i mean
it's like the most amazing
accomplishment and they still are
totally in love with each other i
actually did a two-hour
recorded interview with them on the day
of their anniversary that i wanted to
save
to have my kids watch before they get
married if they choose to get me smart
that's amazing and one of the greatest
things that my dad said i'll never
forget it
is because he knows how much we
struggled heather and i and my parents
love heather and and they
and they saw how hard we tried and and
so my dad said in the interview he says
you know blake i've
often in over the years not just with
you but so many of my friends that have
struggled with their marriages
i've kind of felt guilty because
my marriage here mom has been so easy
he's like it just it just works and i
feel like you know
we just compliment each other in a way
that is
mutually supportive mutually
self-sacrificing it never feels
not never but it hardly has ever felt
like work and
in this interview and i recognize is
that i think they got you know pretty
lucky i mean and he would say so too
they were very young
and every once in a while someone gets
lucky and they just get with the right
person
but what i recognized in the conscious
uncoupling
was i was more interested
in kind of a story
or a perfect picture that i had put in
my mind
largely because of my parents amazing
relationship and my closeness to my
brother and sister
i was more interested in that than
really understanding
who heather was and what was the
foundation of our love so
i was basically had a box and i wanted
to put someone in it and heather
based on her experience which i don't
want to get fully into here
looked like and wanted to jump into my
box
and and that creates a lot of the you
know all the chemicals releasing and the
love feeling and all that
but because we didn't do enough kind of
exploration of really the foundations of
what will make
a relationship work and how you know the
the polarity between masculine and
feminine
you know the the shared you know kind of
you know vision on how we're going to
spend our time our energy
political beliefs and things that kind
of really can get in the way if you
don't really work through them
you know and we just jumped into the you
know the physical attraction and the fun
and all that and we got married
and i don't think either of us were
prepared to and i don't think either of
us
did enough kind of personal work with
each other
to really know what we were signing up
for and
now through the book i was able to see
that i was asking heather
to fulfill needs kind of
like to our earlier conversation of
looking external when you really need to
look internal
i was looking her to fulfill needs that
i had from my childhood patterns
that really weren't the role or the
responsibility of a romantic
partner and lover and and she was
willing to serve those knees because i
was fulfilling some security needs and
other things that she had
verse us really connecting at a romantic
soul level
and so yeah so i mean i'm rambling a
little bit because i think it's
everyone's story is a little different
and i want to you know protect you know
the privacy of the relationship that you
know has been through
i i would say the other thing i just
think that the book does is so well and
the process as well as you just
you know you don't even work with your
partner for the first you know
two to three months or the first two
thirds of the book it's all about
you taking responsibility you
understanding you better
and how you show up in a romantic
relationship or don't
and that was just incredibly powerful
that is a perfect
segue in a sense to what i was going to
ask which is
when does it make sense for someone to
read this book
and also what would your advice be to
couples who
like a lot of couples maybe have their
struggles but aren't yet
code red right is there something they
can do before
they have to kind of yank on the
emergency stop on the train and
start doing triage sure well i think two
things
one is i think you can read the book
even if you're not considering getting
divorced
um even if you're just like in a
relationship and you have your
challenges like everyone else now
obviously i think you got to really
really disclaim
to your partner that uh you're reading
this book to grow your relationship not
to end it or you need to read it on like
a
device that they're not going to see it
i'm just imagining
sitting on the couch cover facing
outward
don't worry about it no don't worry
about it no no it's just yeah
so it's not entertainment value the
cover definitely will make it
if it wasn't in code red it will get to
code red quickly if you don't disclaim
that but i will say actually
if i can recommend another book that
i've also read years ago and have gone
back to reading again
uh and that's by an author named david
dida and that's way of the superior man
and that book the title really doesn't
give it justice because it's
equally important for women to read this
book i believe it's men
but it really helps understand what
the optimal polarity between masculine
and feminine
is and how in some relationships the
woman has the masculine energy and the
male has the feminine energy or in a
homosexual relationship that's
definitely the case
but regardless of what your actual
gender is
if a relationship is going to sustain
the energy that allows you to deal with
all the day-to-day challenges
in a relationship you must serve this
polarity above all else
and heather and i definitely did not do
that
and so i think for anyone in a
relationship that might be having some
challenges maybe doesn't feel the same
way as it did
when you're dating or your early years i
even think before conscious uncoupling
way the superior man i would be highly
recommended
as well and it's a short read it's a
very
fast read short book and
last name is d-e-i-d-a i
i haven't read it a very long time but i
did read it i want to say around
2009 and found it very helpful
and that notion of polarity definitely
stuck
as a kind of marker or litmus test
that's important to be kept in mind and
also something that's important to
cultivate
right which is as opposed to the
directive of the book
in large part i think it's time to get
to
the tactics day-to-day installation
and you gotta first tell me why on earth
start another company
you know the thing that's fun about it
is i would say and i
took spoke to about this several people
now
is what has been so liberating and so
and i wish these were joyful i mean i
have goosebumps as i'm talking about
this and almost starting to shed a tear
as i answer this question because i
really
feel kind of like the message i got in
ayahuasca i have
nothing to prove to anyone i don't need
to make any more money
i don't need to be have my face on the
cover of any more magazines and i say
this with humility not with pride
because that feeling of not having to
prove anything or not having any
expectations has allowed me
to create something maybe even for the
very first time
with such a pureness of serving humanity
that it just lights me up so i don't
even feel there's this great
chateaubriand quote that i love and it
starts with the master of living
does not distinguish between his work
and his leisure
and he goes on and on and then at the
end it says but to him
he lets others you know cast their
judgments on what he is doing but to
himself
he's always doing both at the same time
something like that i
you should get the quote and post it
because it's so good but
this is the moment in my life where i
feel like i'm truly
doing it all at the same time because
i basically took my own suffering as we
spoke about
it led me on a pilgrimage to feel better
i was able to use my relationships and
resources to get
access to top neuroscientists at
stanford and
other scientists from top universities
and
ask them the people who are living i
mean not like
you know extraordinary athletes or or
you know these
amazing specimens but just everyday
people people who have
a normal nine-to-five job who have a
family or no family like people who are
just living but doing everything normal
but still
have a you know an incredible sense of
well-being
and fulfillment and flourishment what
are they doing that science has actually
proven and that was the big difference
is
you know these peak experiences that we
talked about
plant medicine and also hofmann
you know neuroscience says that there's
really two ways to experience
neuroplasticity
it's to have these short intense
experiences like we spoke about
or to find these small steps that can be
done with intention over time and
both ways can allow your brain to change
and your brain changing can affect your
well-being so i went to the scientific
community and said what are these small
things
that i can do every day that other
people have already been doing
and have proven and what i found
was about 10 things and i have a great
business partner in this venture his
name is pat
dossett he was a navy seal for nine
years
he is absolutely obsessed with you know
not just human performance but just
human well-being
uh he also has recognized like me that
we are in as
time and culture where we have some of
the highest dates
of people on antidepressants of all time
we have the highest dates of people
taking sleep aids
highest reports of anxiety and so he is
a man of service and when we connected
he said this is how i think we can serve
people not just
so you personally can feel better but
that we can share this
and so over a year-long journey
and many many amazing meetings and
reviews of
science we were able to find 10
basic fundamental habits and practices
that can transform anyone's life and
definitely have transformed mine and my
ability
to cope with any form of stress
or challenges thrown at me and that
ultimately became
uh what we launched on march 4th and
that's called made for
in what form does the
service or product take what is it yeah
so it's that's
that's one of the interesting things are
two macro philosophies of the program
that science really showed us and that
was number one is it's very hard for
people to make
sustaining change in their habits or
lifestyle
if they're trying to learn more than one
thing at a time and it takes about
30 days to really ingrain a new habit or
practice so one
aspect of the program is is that we only
will teach you
and help you learn and integrate one
thing at a time for 30 days
so the program is 10 months long where
you focus on one thing each month
and the second thing and this is what
really distinguishes it from many many
different
you know offerings in the market right
now is
we found that it needed to be completely
analog
there could be no app there could be no
digital device there could be no
you know gadget that tells you how
you're doing you had to be able to feel
it internally
for it to take root and to be um
to be the most effective from a
neuroplasticity standpoint
and so the program is actually mailed to
you
each month in a kit and so the kit has
three components in it the first thing
is it has is all the science curated
into a very
simple 20-minute read it's a little book
that has been written in
very easy to understand terms that gives
you
basically an understanding of what
you're going to learn and why it's so
critical to your well-being
the second thing is a tool that we that
we design that's unique to the made-for
program and this tool is something
you're going to interact and use for 30
days as you learn this new habit or
practice
and then the third thing is a challenge
card
and a little bracelet that you wear that
reminds you of your commitment that
month
so some visual cues and the challenge
card is a way to kind of get the
dopamine hit
every day as you complete whatever
you're doing that day during the month
and that's what comes in the kit and so
it comes once a month and then when you
complete that when you go to the next
one but i
i want to pause for one second to say
because i think 10
months and 10 new things can feel
overwhelming to people
the goal of made for is not to teach you
10 new habits now
you might really integrate all 10 into
your life but most of our members who've
gone through
already we had 1300 people go through
the beta over a year period
you know there's three or four things
that really really stick
and those three or four things have a
huge effect on
their well-being and mental health and
physical health and so what we're really
trying to do
is help you shift your mindset more than
anything
and your behavior verse learn 10 new
things but we have to teach you
these and have you have these 10
experiences over this prolonged period
of time
for that to take place what are i love
the fact that it's analog only just as a
side note
just why i knew that would resonate well
with you
yeah why why still do so much by hand
uh like an old timer but what are some
of the
habits and practices can you give any
examples yeah so
the thing that was the most surprising
and i think encouraging
um at least from um the learning
experience was
these are things that we all know
already or most of them
um so one of the examples uh the most
simple
and foundational one is the importance
of hydration
and so what we found is there is a large
percentage of
americans that are chronically
dehydrated even though they say they
drink water
the science shows that every person's
need for water throughout the day
is very different based on the climate
you live in the diet your activity
levels etc
but our body is made of seventy percent
water
and even a one percent change
in your optimal hydration can affect
your mood
your energy levels i mean a lot of
people have to have that
caffeine shot midday i found that once i
got my hydration practice dialed in
that's not as necessary anymore and so
hydration is one that's very simple and
so i'll just walk you through what the
hydration
month could look like just to kind of
give you an idea of what the other
months and i can share some of the other
practices but
you know so we really teach you and we
take
all kind the [ __ ] and miss of eight
ounces or eight glasses of water or
electrolytes or all this stuff that
has been created to sell you stuff and
we really look at the science of
hydration and we distill that down to a
20 minute read and explain to you why
it's so critical
that this is something you need to
really master if you're going to live
your best life
the second thing is we've designed a
beautiful water bottle that keeps track
or helps you keep track of how much
water you're drinking during the day
and it very specifically has these beads
on it they're almost kind of like a
prayer bead
that you move along this cord every time
you finish a bottle
what the neuroscience shows us is that
you get a dopamine hit every time you
move a bead
so not only are you feeling better
because you're better hydrated
but you're also getting that dopamine
hit when you tactically move this
on the bottle and the bottle is as
beautiful as something that would look
you'd find in the moma so it's something
you're proud to carry around
and have some identity with and then the
third part of the hydration is the
challenge of you know how many beads
you're trying to get to
and also a journaling exercise so you
can reinforce the benefits
of that you're feeling when you get
properly hydrated now the thing i love
about this
is everything in made for has what i
would call a micro
and macro mindset intervention so the
micro
part of this is is that we hope after
the end of the month you'll fully have a
hydration practice and you will be the
type of person that's drinking water
throughout the day and you'll know
approximately how much you need to be
drinking to feel your best but the macro
thing that's happening inside of your
brain when you're doing this is you are
building
a fortitude of understanding that i'm
the type of person that can stick to
something for 30 days
because a lot of people maybe never have
stuck to something for 30 days like this
and so by making it so simple as
drinking water then you're better
prepared when the next
month comes and maybe it's a little bit
more challenging because you've just had
the benefit and the
and the satisfaction and the momentum
created
of sticking with something for 30 days
so that already is changing and priming
your brain to take on other experiences
i think that's very important that you
are building
the meta capability of
instilling and following habits that
strikes me as incredibly
significant that you're certainly taking
on these different practices
and these different tools but
in following one thing for 30 days and
repeating that cycle
10 times you are proving to yourself
and also sharpening the saw of skill
acquisition
and habit formation absolutely and then
after that
then you can choose what your next 30
days look like and then the 30 days
after that and then
30 days after that so that strikes me as
very very important what are some other
examples besides hydration yeah so
another one
um is and i know you have studied this
and you've already referenced it in the
podcast is you know we went
very very deep on optimizing the perfect
night's sleep
and and how important sleep really is
as a foundational practice and so those
are two that
i would say are more physical in nature
a mental one would be
a gratitude practice now we've all heard
that gratitude is an important
experience to be having an emotion um
and that you know having a gratitude
journal can help you with your mental
health and
but we went much deeper than that and we
really looked at
different areas of your life where you
often
are missing out an opportunity to
express
gratitude and then change the way that
you approach challenging situations in
the future
and also really looking at how gratitude
can
strengthen very important relationships
in your life that we know have been
scientifically proven to affect just
you know how many times a year you get
sick and your longevity
and gratitude instead of doing the same
thing every day for 30 days like
hydration
it's a series of different experiences
you do every week
that kind of get more and more difficult
as the weeks go on and so at the end of
the month
you've done four very unique experiences
around gratitude
some by yourself and some involving
other people
so that then you have a tool set of
ways to experience gratitude for your
well-being
as you go forward but it's not
necessarily something you're committing
to every single day for the rest of your
life
and so that's an example of one that
would affect more of the
of the mental capacity um and and
ultimately what we're trying to do as we
work through these things and they get
more challenging as you go is really
address your physical health your mental
health
and what i would call either your
spiritual or if you're not spiritual
your purposeful health you know
how do you and that's where the name
made for came from
is ultimately we're not just trying to
help you understand
from a science perspective what you're
made of in a very easy fun
way to engage but also answer this
question what am i made for
and i think at some point in all of our
lives we ask that question so we're
creating a very systematic way
for you to ultimately uh get to an
answer to that
i dig it i dig it man i need to i need
to get that
that gratitude module
asap i need to correct my bad habits
well what's been
interesting is is you laugh about that
but like um
you know it is we launched okay well we
launched this you know we launched
we did a year's worth of beta group um
and then we decided to launch on march
4th
you know right before covid19 and we
you know have had about a thousand
people going through the program
during um quarantine and it's been
amazing to see how this has created such
a resilience
to the anxiety and the uncertainty and
many of the things that we've been
feeling and
that's why i was excited to come on the
podcast now because i think
the two things that are going to be
hopefully most beneficial to people
as we try to get back to normal life
number one is there's going to be a
higher rate
of divorce than ever in our country's
history is what all the
uh experts in that field are telling me
because i have been doing some more
research and looking to do some more
philanthropy there to help people
with the conscious uncoupling and number
two is is people
need you know lost their jobs they've
lost their security they've lost
uh they have a tremendous amount of
uncertainty coming out and so to help
people with these
daily habits and practices that can
really help them reintegrate
um is i think very time sensitive oh i
could not agree more and i was 100
serious on the gratitude the the you
mentioned two things
that have such historically had such
incredible ripple effects in my life
namely optimizing sleep and regular
gratitude practice
yeah that nonetheless
for whatever reason i am prone to
neglecting it's
really embarrassing to admit and a
30-day reboot
sounds like for me at least exactly what
the doctor ordered
and i agree that it's time sensitive and
it will always be time sensitive sure in
some respects
and people can find more at
getmade4.com is that the right yep
that's the website that's correct yes
roger that so people can find more
information at getmade4.com obviously
i'll put that in the show notes
as well i think this is a good place to
begin to wrap up
and is is there anything else that
you would like to say before we begin to
come to a close here no i just you know
like i said at the beginning
i just am appreciative to you for our
friendship and
and our ability to connect on so many
things but
for having me back on because i'm
realizing as i realized the first time
that like
being able to talk in this long form and
reflect on some of the things that have
had the biggest impact
on my life and the main changes i've had
it is kind of a
therapy session so i've been really
blessed
uh i feel really complete um and
uh and i feel that you know i don't know
if i'll ever reach a state
of feeling fully awakened or enlightened
as we read about it in the many many
spiritual
books that exist and accounts that some
people have had
in that but you know i i do feel that
like there is a moment and i think i'm
having one right now where i
i've really done the work and by doing
the work and sharing the work with
others and helping other people do the
work
i'm seeing that it can work and you can
uh live in a state of real flourishing
and
that's my hope is that this conversation
has
inspired uh someone in the many you know
myriad of topics that we covered
to dig a little bit deeper into some
personal work uh
and the inner adventure that they
possibly are ready to go on
so thank you thank you blake and you
know i mentioned gratitude practice why
not start now
if not now when tim ferriss and i i will
just say
that i also really value our friendship
and savor it i mean that might sound
strange
value sounds almost too quantifiable it
it's something that i've found very
nourishing over there
over particularly the last handful of
years when we've had more contact
and it's impressed me how
you often very transparently view
yourself as a work in progress as we all
are
and i appreciate you also sharing your
struggles
because as i heard someone say once you
know everyone's fighting
a battle you know nothing about and it's
easy to feel alone
it's easy for people to feel alone
isolated or in some way uniquely flawed
and in a sense it's very heartening
to have someone vulnerably share
their stories and talk about conscious
and coupling and
chapters and transitions that have no
doubt at points been very very
hard so i appreciate that about you and
appreciate the friendship
and uh thanks for coming back for a
round two yeah
we'll see in another five or ten years
i well the good news is i got bald early
so i've already
crossed that rubicon so i will not be
getting any more bald
and getmade4.com is the website people
can find you on social
at blakemykosky on instagram twitter
facebook
and once again i really appreciate you
taking the time thanks tim and to
everybody listening
we'll put links to everything in the
show notes at tim.log forward slash
podcast just search blake and it will
pop
right up and until next time continue
to determine what are you made for
not just what are you made of and uh
go easy go easy yeah it's easy don't be
too hard on yourself
especially during these covid times
we're all a work in progress thanks for
tuning in
hey guys this is tim again just a few
more things before you take off
number one this is five bullet friday do
you want to get
a short email from me would you enjoy
getting a short email from me every
friday
that provides a little morsel of fun
before the weekend
and five bullet friday is a very short
email where i share
the coolest things i've found or that
i've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that i've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that i've somehow dug up
in the uh the world of the esoteric as i
do it could include
favorite articles that i've read and
that i've shared with
my close friends for instance and it's
very short
it's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend so
if you want to receive that
check it out just go to four
hourworkweek.com that's
4hourworkweek.com all spelled out and
just drop in
your email and you will get the very
next one and if you sign up
i hope you enjoy it this episode is
brought to you by
read wise read wise is one of the cooler
things i've found
in the last year or two sent to me by
one of my best friends
it is an app that helps you remember
significantly more of what you
read in fact on average their users
report remembering 84
more of what they've read and
highlighted
and it can take a few different forms
you can sign up for the service
that's readwise.io forward slash tim
and get a daily email which i do so i've
got in front of me one example of
highlights from food by randomness
sapiens
priceless and a bunch of other books and
it has a bunch of
advanced features on top of that but
we've all had the experience of reading
a book or article looking back a couple
of weeks later to realize that you don't
remember
anything from it or next to nothing read
wise solves this problem by integrating
with kindle pocket
ibooks insta paper and more to send you
a daily digest of all your highlights
so it helps you to build a fun daily
habit i love getting these emails which
i can't believe i'm even saying cause i
hate email but i love getting these
so you get a daily email and simplest
form and you can review and actually use
the hundreds or perhaps even thousands
of highlights that are just sitting in
your reading devices collecting cyber
dust and this simple habit of reviewing
your highlights daily
can dramatically improve how much
information you retain through spaced
repetition and actually
use and quite frankly it's just fun it's
really fun to see what you've
highlighted over the years and forgotten
about
some of it's really good i mean these
are things that ostensibly you wanted to
remember
readwise also provides tools for
organizing your books articles and
highlights
so tagging searching adding notes
creating flash cards
all that kind of stuff you can even tell
read wise to automatically export your
highlights to evernote
this is a big deal for me i've had to do
this manually in the past but read wise
makes it
painless and super super simple and it
just takes
seconds to sign up i was astonished by
this i thought the importing from the
kindle would take a really long time
it takes no time at all and believe it
or not you can also use read wise
with paper books that is if you have a
paperback or something
you can automatically get the top
popular highlights for your books simply
by adding their titles
and you can also create your own
highlights with the app's camera
highlighting feature
this stuff is super cool so there's no
reason not to try this out
i think it's incredibly incredibly
useful incredibly cool and very fun
go to read wise dot io forward slash tim
it's read wise dot io forward slash tim
for two month free trial
offered exclusively to tim ferris show
listeners again that's read wise dot io
forward slash tim for two month free
trial rewise dot io
forward slash tim check it out this
episode is brought to you by ascent
protein i've been using ascent as my
primary protein powder for
three years now it's clean efficient
super easy on the stomach ever since i
wrote for our body
starting my day with at least 30 grams
of protein has been part of
my routine it's part of the slow carb
diet it's used
to recompose your body to lose fat etc
it's very effective
ascend protein is the easiest way to get
this done sometimes you just don't feel
like cooking a meal
i trust ascent because they offer what
most companies
can't premium protein they control the
production
from start to finish they're vertically
integrated there are zero artificial
ingredients
zero artificial sweeteners and zero
added sugar they really do their
homework in r d this impressed me when i
was having tons of email back and forth
to try to assess them as one example
they tested 282
versions of the chocolate flavor which
is my favorite
before getting it just right a few more
things all ascent products are informed
sports certified to be free of ban
substances one scoop
contains 25 grams of protein and more
muscle repairing
bcaas is or branched chain amino acids
than an equivalent serving of chicken
beef eggs or salmon
they also are gluten free and soy free
so you add one scoop
or one and a half scoops to a shaker
bottle that's what i do
let's say five to six ounces of water
and you can do that in the morning as i
do you do post workout as i also do
after kettlebell swings and so on
you shake it up and you have a full
serving of elite protein in less than 60
seconds
so take a look check it out i have my
entire pantry stocked with this stuff
with the chocolate specifically check
out ascent
protein that's a-s-c-e-n-t
protein dot com forward slash tim and
use the code
tim ascent for 20 off your purchase
again that's
ascentproteam.com tim
and use code tim ascent for 20 off the
discount code will also work on
amazon.com if you shop ascent protein
again it's tim ascent as a code for 20
of us